[Music]
ah
i'll be back
hey everybody what's going on it's bobby
and i'm back dressed very differently
today
reason being is we are testing out the
huawei free buds for i've been playing
with them for the past couple weeks and
you've probably seen a number of videos
of you know these video reviewers
walking on the streets sitting in their
home studios giving you the lowdown on
these but we know with wireless earbuds
we just don't sit at home and listen to
music we're out there exercising we're
cycling we're out there in the
environment so how do these perform when
i'm riding a bicycle when i'm running
around do they fall out what's the noise
canceling like what's the volume like
what's the audio quality like when i'm
outside let's put these through their
paces let's find out
[Music]
now before we get into things let's talk
a little bit about the design of these
earbuds and just the overall usability
now the design
look we know what they look like right
elephant in the room they look like the
old airpods but that's not a bad thing
this is a tried and true design these
are an earbud that does not go inside
the ear canal they sit on the outside
some people like this some people don't
i prefer this type of earbud especially
if i'm outside because i can still hear
the outside surroundings you know if i'm
riding my bike on the roads or if i'm in
traffic i still know what's around me
now these also come in two colors they
have a ceramic white and they have this
sort of uh they call it frosted silver
or frosted color but it looks like a
gunmetal chrome
very beautiful very sexy i prefer this
color over the white because the white
looks like an airpod this has a much
more distinct look and it actually
matches my bike a little bit in my
personal opinion in terms of the case
it's small it's circular it's
lightweight in design it charges it does
what you need to do it's a no-frills
case it's not too heavy and it's not
super light
it's just good it's right it's perfect
what you need it to be so let's talk
battery life for a moment with these
because uh the battery life is pretty
impressive now with anc off active noise
cancelling off you get about 22 hours of
battery and then about four hours of
play time through you know one charge of
the earbuds now when you have anc on
uh that does diminish a little bit you
get about 14 hours total battery life
and about 2.5 hours on a single charge
out of the earbuds so still gonna get
you through a full workout um you know
for cycling like i said if you're
outdoors you really don't need to have
anc on so you can maximize that battery
life also these are wireless charging
earbuds with inside the case so you can
uh utilize that if you want and if you
want a quick charge 15 minutes gives you
2.5 hours of usage out of these buds so
and in terms of my real world testing i
would say that those numbers are about
right um it's kind of hard to equate
because how we use our earbuds the
volume a and c on anc off it's really
hard to sort of be scientific with these
tests but i can say that i've never had
an issue with the battery life for the
couple weeks that i've been using them
and also the case is very small very
pocketable i can swipe it into the back
pocket here on my cycling jersey throw
into my jeans pocket it's lightweight
you don't feel it's there um i think
huawei's done a good job with the design
of these it's kind of like a no-frills
case i've never been like going god i
got to charge these they're just they're
dying out really quick that's never
happened to me i use these in the gym i
use them cycling around and they have
been a joy to use in that regard
but let's talk about active noise
cancelling now active noise cancelling
on these is it's it's an interesting
concept here because these are not an
earbud that sits inside your ear canal
or it sort of seals your ear canal and
that's really where you see the benefit
of active noise cancelling in a lot of
earbuds or overhead headphones for that
matter so with these
it works but it's not going to be like
what you're used to if you're in a quiet
room and you have some white noise in
the background
then it you're going to notice a
difference if i'm outdoors like this i
don't notice a difference on or off you
also have some nice touch controls on
the earbuds which is nice so you can
actually adjust the volume by uh swiping
up and down on these and also you can
tap onto the side of these on each of
them to like pause music fast forward
answer phone calls all that so in that
regard it works relatively well um but
they do sit pretty light in your ears so
you have to put a little bit of force
and touch
and go up and down like that so it's
something to take note of you got to
know based on the design how these are
like and they're also very light in the
ear so once you have them in your ears
you kind of forget after a while that
they're actually there
so that's kind of a nice thing because
the worst thing is when you're
exercising you're out and about
you're like you know what i don't this
thing in my ear really bothers me after
so long you don't feel that with these
three butt fours they have always done a
nice job with weight design ergonomics
to give you a nice balance in your ear
in that regards with the huawei app that
you sync these up to you do have some
extra controllers to it so you can
adjust the eq a little bit you can do
bass boost treble boost or just flat um
with the noise cancelling you can do you
can change that as well you have a
couple different modes on that
you can do you find my earbuds you can
choose the left or the right one to find
which is a nice added bonus
and yeah you just got your basic
settings overall so these are kind of
like a no-frills earbud
but do the job of playing your music
playing your uh your video tracks
playing whatever it is you want to
listen to and you're gonna have really
good audio quality as a matter of fact
speaking of video for a moment so watch
youtube sometimes one of the downsides
of bluetooth earbuds is you get a delay
when you're watching video that's not
the case with the free bud force it is
synced with the person's mouth and voice
so it sounds as you'd be like watching a
normal tv show without earbuds you're
getting that same sort of uh response
from these which is a very good thing
anyway so now i'm going to ride around
i'm going to put these through their
paces i'm going to cycle i'm going to
jog let's see how they perform
[Music]
[Applause]
so as we saw in cycling the fitment
feels just as good jogging right now
it's not bouncing on my ears it feels
solid even though it's lightweight the
three by fours feel really really good
and the audio quality has improved now
i've updated to ios 15 the beta version
from ios 14. now there's a difference in
terms of volume ios 14
the volume was a little bit low on the
free but fours but the 15 it's increased
uh tremendously so it sounds really good
uh voices are clear great bass great
dynamics i'm just really impressed with
this overall
uh
yeah these are really really solid
anyway zach you slow down a second slow
down slow down hold on it's okay final
thoughts
on the free bud fours
you know
they're an attractive earbuds as you can
tell
this silver frost that they're calling
but i call like a gunmetal chrome look
are very attractive the price of 198
singapore dollars isn't uh inexpensive
but it's not as expensive as others out
there
and the performance works on ios well
works on android of course very well and
huawei's own version of their phones so
these are a really good option for you
to explore if you're looking for
wireless earbuds and especially if you
want to do outdoor activities like
cycling and jogging
i think you're going to really enjoy
these anyway those are my thoughts on
the free blood force let me know your
thoughts in the comment section below do
you like these are you looking to pick
these up any questions you have hit us
up we'll try to answer them for you with
that stay safe stay healthy we'll see
the next one take care come on zacky
come on come on
come on
come on
[Music]